hello youtube chance Larsen offense this
is goon Chen here
happy Christmas to all of you and today
is a very special day for me because GHS
has reached more than 10 thousand
subscribers I like to thank you from
bottom of my heart and all the credit
goes to you guys thank you for your
wonderful ongoing support in today's
lecture
dirty chess tricks fire I like to show
you some of the nice chest tricks exist
against the Philidor defense now before
we move on once again I like to mention
that here I'm only going to cover the
tricks I am not covering the whole
theory so if you have any doubt please
look out the theory section of this
variation
after E 4 E 5 and nightwear 3 the usual
response from the black side is the
classical which is nice to see 6 or the
other defense is the patter of defense
but there is a third alternative and
let's start with the MU D 6 and this is
known as a filardo defense eventually
fill out a defense lots its popularity
because of the very dangerous central
attack by the white and that start with
the move d4 you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows over here
black has few options but amongst them
ecaptions' b4 leads to a very passive
position for black and same can be said
by Knight to f6 which can be easily met
by D captures efore so other two moves
need to be considered and the first move
I like to consider over here is Knight
to d7 and this is probably the starting
point of the filler or defense well here
there are few moves but the best move
from the white perspective is Bishop to
c4 and it contains lots of tricks
once again black has few options but
believe it or not they all leads to a
very miserable position and it's a great
fun to watch all of them so let's see
each by turn first more I want to
consider is Knight G to f6 so nature
looking move developing a king side
piece but once again it leads to a
disaster offer D captures ePHI
here black has three options but all
leads to worse position for black if D
captures Aoife then after a very simple
lie to g5 black has a huge problem
defending the f7 and I don't think so
and there's any satisfactory way to
defend this pawn so that's not good if
Knight captures efore then after Queen
to defy black is in a great danger of
losing a piece because not only white is
threatening to capture this Knight but
white is also threatening to mate black
on f7 so black has to more or less
forget about the piece and try to defend
the f7 and the third option which is
Knight captures ePHI once again leads to
favourable position for white so here
white will continue with Knight captures
night and after D captures night white
will give this wonderful check which is
Bishop cross Epsilon and black King will
capture this bishop for a glance it
looks like white gained the queen of the
black but after the whole sequence which
is Bishop check and there's a discord
attack to the Queen
so Queen has to drop back to d2 and
after Bishop captures Queen and Knight
captures after the whole transaction
white emerge with a clear pawn up and a
better position so that means at this
position Knight G to f6 is prohibited
let's look at another move which is
Bishop to e7 after Bishop to e7 once
again white will capture the e5 pawn and
black has two options
d captures ePHI then after Queen to defy
once again black is having some problem
on the f7 square and the only way to
defend this square is by playing Knight
to f6 which can be easily made by a
bishop captures at 6 and black has the
only choice left is to castle on the
King side afterwards white will just
simply drop that Bishop back and emerge
with a clear piece up if at this point
Knight captures ePHI then white will
capture this Knight and after black
recapture with the pawn White has a
sneaky move that is Queen to h5 so
hitting the too soft spot and black
cannot defend both of them so in this
variation let's say after black plays g6
to save the mate White Queen will simply
snap up the e5 pawn and at least remain
upon up so that means Bishop e7 is also
prohibited you might think moves such as
s6 will stop any tricks by white but
witness yourself because once again what
is going to capture the e pawn
and black capture with the night then
white will capture this night and after
black recapture we have this Bishop
captures f7 and at least white will gain
upon in this radiation so very obvious
is at this point black has to capture
with the pawn Saudi captures e-file and
now White has this amazing piece
sacrifice that is Bishop captures f7
King to e7 looks hopeless so black has
to accept this sacrifice and after this
White has this night check now please
note this night is pin
so that means black has only few options
left with the King and all of them leads
to a quick check made by white so let's
see all of them first book if King to e7
then Knight to g6 will gain at least a
rook if the King goes to the ER square
then Queen to h5 is a deadly check and
that means the black King will be on the
dance floor
so a simple line run like this so King
to be 7 and then Quint we have 7 and the
dance begin with King to d6
and we have some Muse like this
afterwards
black king will be checkmated after King
to e6 Queen to defy check and King to f6
leads to a very fast checkmate so we
should see this move so here right we'll
continue with Queen check and after
black recaptures Bishop check and King
to d4 and Queen to D far as a checkmate
last but not least black has the move
King to f6
afterwards it doesn't look like white
has anything concrete but believe it or
not white has a sneaky developing move
which create a big big problem to the
black King and that is the move Knight
to c3 here to moose has been try if
black plays Bishop to b4 pinning that
night then white can play the move Queen
to d4 and not only white is threatening
the bishop but what is also threatening
to give a discover check to the black
king so our sample line can run like
this so Bishop capture c3 and after B
capture c3 the best move suggested by
Fritz is Queen to e8 afterwards white
can simply snap up that night and not
only white regain the peace but white
has attacked a boot in the second line
black greedily captured that piece so
King captures e5
I got this position in one of my game
and I must admit I was enjoying the
black King dance so here I continue with
the move Queen to defy check and after
King to f6 Queen to f4 check and after
King to e7 Knight to d5 check occurs
and following moves are like this so my
opponent King run like a hell but after
a few moves like this
I made the checkmate the final move we
have is the moves c6 but here white can
again continue with the move d captures
ePHI and black has to play D captures e5
because if black captures with the
knight then the formula trick happens
which is Knight captures night and after
D captures ePHI we have a lovely Bishop
cross F cell here instead of immediately
capturing the night if you open and try
to be smart with the Queen check so
Queen to a5 check then white can
continue with the move Knight to c3 and
after D captures e5 white can develop
all of his species starting with the
move Queen to h5 so threatening on f7
and a sample line can run like this so
after g6 Queen to f3 which are once
again renewing the threat to web server
so that more or less force black to play
Queen to c7 afterwards white can play
the move Bishop to g5 and you can
already see although material is
balanced White has almost developed all
of his species and why it has a
flexibility of castling with side so
that means Knight captures ePHI is
prohibited that leads to the only move
left that is D captures ePHI here white
will continue with the move Knight to g5
attacking f7 so night at six is forced
and now white will castle on the King
side and at first sight it looks like
Bishop to e7 is a very obvious move
because it's hitting the knight and also
black is one step away from the castle
well all looks good and rosy for black
except white next move that is Knight to
e6 BAM so hitting the Queen hitting the
g7 and I think some of the good top
layers including onon get this position
lucky them so black the sponsors force
black has to accept this piece sacrifice
afterwards White will continue with the
move Bishop captures at six and black
cannot capture this piece if black
captured the bishop then after Queen
check and King to f8 White has this move
Bishop captures e6 which leads to the
checkmate on f7 and the only way to
defend the checkmate is by a queen to e8
but Queen captures at six and this is a
checkmate and many people has fallen
into this one
even though let's say after visual
capture that six if you open and doesn't
capture this Bishop and it played a
strong move that is night to be six
might will continue here with the move
Queen to h4 check and both the Mookie to
f8 and King to d7 can be successfully
made by a f4 and rook to d1 so the only
good move left is g6 and afterwards so
it will just drop this Queen back to the
e2 and although if you look at the
position carefully the material is
balanced white has this wonderful bishop
sitting on at six with stopping black to
castle on the King side and black has
this horrible double points and that is
more than enough compensation to win the
game
so those are some of the wonderful
tricks exist in 92 d7 variation now
let's look at some of the tricks exist
in the MU f5 which is known as filler or
counter gambit
after the move f5 it's not advisable for
white to taking either of the pawns
instead of this what should continue
with the move Bishop to c4 and again the
ball is back into the black squad
because if black is going to capture
either of the born then there are some
nasty tricks waiting to be it so let's
see them first obvious looking move is f
captures efore which has a merit of
hitting the night and here why it has
this amazing piece sacrifice that is
Knight captures e-file no matter how
black react for example whether black
capture the knight or push forward it
all leads to a bad position to the black
if pawn captures night then after this
Queen check black is in a great great
difficulties because the simple looking
move g6 can lose a rook in the corner so
that's not possible
and if the King goes to the e7 then
after Queen captures ePHI white queen is
asking black where you going sweetie and
after King to d7 Queen to e6 will simply
trap the black sweetie so that's not
good either the last move King to d7
will allow black King to come to the
dance floor once again after Queen to a5
check I got this position in one of my
game and the game continues like this so
after King to c6
I simply capture the e pawn and now
there are so many threats are looming so
the first threat is Queen to be Phi I
can also capture this a pawn
there's also threat of Bishop to f4 so
all in all after long thinking my
opponent responded over here with the
move a six but after this the task
become very easy for me so game
continues like this I give him this defy
check and after King to b6 I just give
this
the bishop III check and after a few
moves like this
I made him the checkmate so that means
at this position pawn captures Aoife is
not good if black plays the move defy
then after once again Queen check and g6
white will simply capture that pawn and
the h1 is spin so black cannot capture
the knight and what is threatening to
capture the room
that means black is false is pretty much
forced black has to play first of all
Knight to f6 hitting the Queen and here
white will continue with the move Queen
to e5 check and no matter how black
plays this position white will have a
winning continuation after all the
fireworks so let's see them after Bishop
to b7 Knight captures Bishop and Queen
captures night here why it has this move
Bishop to g4 and to continuation has
been tried in the first move white
capture the Queen but after very simple
D captures Aoife hitting the night and
if the knight moves then the d5 pawn
drops so black has to forcefully accept
this bishop and after white will gain
the night and after this not only white
is a clear pawn up but blacks King side
pawn or shut up
instead of this if black captured the
bishop Saudi captured c4 then after very
simple Bishop captures f6 hitting the
roof and hitting the Queen black has to
forcefully accept the queen trade and
after this once again white emerge with
a clear pawn up and blacks king position
is shattered so all in all F captures e4
it's not advisable in this position if
black plays he captures d4 then why
should continue with the move Knight to
g5 looking at the f7 so black responses
force black has to play Knight to f6
afterwards
white will simply castle on the King
side and here to lose has been tried
both leads to wonderful tricks so we
should see them in the first move black
plays Bishop to e7 afterwards White has
this lethal check that is Queen to h5
and g6 is not possible because Queen
captures at 6 and white gained a
valuable piece so that means King has to
come to the f8 afterwards Knight to f7
will folk major pieces so only way to
come out is moving the Queen so let's
say Queen goes to the DA afterwards
White has this amazing shot Bishop
captures at 6 and black cannot capture
this and that means white will emerge
with a clearly superior position now
instead of Bishop to e7
if white goes for the pawn hunt so F
captures efore then white can play this
tricky move rook to e1 and once again
two moves has been tried in first
variation black plays the move III so
Queen is hitting the night here white
should ignore this and sacrifice the
Nile with a very amazing initiative so
here white will continue with the move
Queen captures d4 and after Queen
captures g5 right we'll take this pawn
with the bishop position is very very
dangerous for black
because not only this Bishop is hitting
the Queen but once this bishop moved
then there will be a discover attack to
the black king in this game black
continue with the move Queen to g4
but after Bishop to g5 black King
doesn't survive longer so let me show
you the rest of the moves very quickly
black plays Queen to d7 afterwards white
player strong but very effective blue
King to e3 so going for the mate idea in
the game black plays this c5 but that
doesn't stop the mate because after
Queen to d8 and King to c7 Bishop to d8
is a checkmate
instead of e3 if black plays the move
defy
then once again white can sacrifice a
piece via night captures e4 and no
matter how black recaptured black has
the lost position so let's see if D
captures c4 then after Queen check one
of my opponent block this check with
denied but to his horror he find out
that night to have six is a checkmate so
that is wonderful right instead of this
if D captures efore then white can throw
this check with rook captures e4 and
after Bishop to e7 first white will rip
open the King side wire Bishop captures
at six and after G craft just at six
once again our old friend that is Queen
to h5 check the only move left is King
to d7 afterwards rook captures d4 will
finish black off so here black doesn't
have any option black has to play Bishop
to d6 afterwards Queen to f5 check King
to e7 white just checkmate the blacking
on the f7
so those are some of the wonderful
tricks exist in Philadelphia gambit by
looking at this tricks today you can
meet the filardo defense very
confidently and you have every chance to
finish your opponent early in the game
well thank you for watching this video
and I'll meet you soon
bye